what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch today House of
the Dragon dracaris John how's the flame in your
loins it is bright and and burn and how's your
loin doing it's it is a it's I gotta get a check
by a doctor ladies and gentlemen strike that like
button I know you can doesn't take much effort
on your hands please go ahead and do it also
subscribe click that notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction for the finale of
House of the Dragons up here on the channel also
uh full-length Reaction watch along is resync with
your own copy available for super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page thank you so much to everyone who
has joined but more importantly thank you to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video that is
the VPN that we actually use here at Zario rejects
so it makes for the most natural Partnerships and
will tell you why we like to use them specifically
after the reaction anyway let's get to it
oh is this like right after viserys died
with his own eyes you guys
stay here tell them tell no one who knows
I have made him tell you some of
the servants he's the Spy right
last night she told me you wish for
egg on to be king oh [__] foreign
the king is dead
but he has left us a gift with his
last breath he impressed upon the
queen his final wish that his son should
succeed him oh no the Seven Kingdoms
like immediately tell the council I have known
this errors longer than any who sit at this table
and I will not believe that he said this
on his death bed alone with only the boy's
mother as a witness thank you yeah the
King was well last night my whole account
which of you here can swim
that he died of his own accord
whether it was one of you or all of you oh my
God I care not I will have no thoughts whoa
oh my God that's taken care of throw down
your sword and remove your cloaks of Kristen
I am your lord command as a Christian I
will not suffer insults to how Grace the
queen there was no insult to me you decide your
blade this is such an upsetting conversation
yeah everyone's true colors coming out
for my rare cannot of course be allowed to
remain free and draw support to her claim
you mean to imprison she and her family will be
given the opportunity to publicly swear a basement
to the new king oh you scum your father is correct
your grace living Challenger invites battle and
bloodshed and War will happen it's coming where
you like it or not the king wouldn't wish for
any of them wish for the murder of his daughter
yeah he loved her I'll not have you denied this
word and I'll have you removed from this chamber
and sent to the wall yeah crush your head on
the spot Lord Commander westerling take your
Knights the Dragonstone be quick and be clean
and until that is one I have no place here
does he get to collect unemployment
she's going to naturally get
promoted now where is that going
not here he's not in his rooms
he's probably doing something very admirable right
now I believe he may have left the keep Secret
gone into the city find him bring him
to me and me alone Sir Eric map this
plan out for so long puppet master I really
didn't expect it to just kick off like this
I'm gonna have to keep a close eye on all of
you until this is sorted out oh this is so
so disturbing I've had the worst worst kind
of negative nipple chills this entire time
I'll come with you that
would not be my desire amen
Cole needs me mother so Eric isn't the
only one who knows acorns doing he's
very inconspicuous look at him he'll blend
right in right in want to hear eye patch
the prince is not here has he been here Dahlia
perhaps quite a bit earlier years ago in fact more
recently it is not frequent the street of silk
his tastes are known to be less discriminating
oh I wish you luck good sir
and my best to your friend
how you've grown nature remembers
all the series amended his
I just wanna you once wore your Banners
To renira I don't know what I want to do
but you want to do it and you want to do it best
I must confer first with my house on this matter
you'll not leave this room without declaring
your intention you are such a prick
he's loyal to an error I am no oath
breaker I will not bend the knee how well
what a crock of [__] please this
way to execute you single file
oh he's bending the knee Oh I thought
you were the good one as long as the king
you're doing so good for sarath you're just
so good I couldn't hear the whole thing up
he's in an underground Fight
Club down come here come back
he isn't an underground Fight Club
little kids come on they have to grow their
nails and file the teeth oh my God
spends many a night in this place
my God one of many had wager
wow holy moly that is so twisted
all right guys Team Green at the real Rejects
bend the knee what can I have no choice now
we're in I just like saying that to upset you
desire who trains with the sword who rides the
largest dragon in the world desires you should be
yeah I know what it is to toil
for what others have really given
and we can't find him Cole be our decent man
with no taste for depravity all right are we
oh something must be done oh my God
is he gonna report he's got a crisis
of conscience brewing a moment of your time Lords
you'll find no buyers for your words here I think
you've been seen spotted you know what I mean
all right up man I know oh oh I have
no love for the princess where were
you going then it's such urgency
let the king's Justice take him
come on man you had like 10
minutes to think of a lie
you know I'm trying to hate her but I
just feel bad I know everyone hates her
so much and everyone's using her
in one way or another like jeez
she really did love him
or have a love for him yeah she
must now finish his model of
old valyria I just want to check in
with renera make sure she's okay and
how's valarian has long Allied itself with the
princess rhaenyra and what has it gained you
the word of my house is not no true Queen
let's make a window in the wall of your prison
wait where is this going
oh what that's turn have a ring the
bell when you have an answer have a
Queens to be Battle Royale it's gonna
be like when Arnold ran for governor
everyone's gonna want to be on that yep you
yourself are the mysterious white worm I take
it or are you simply a further people
in this stinking onion my condolence is
nicely done where's the prince
oh nice you go close to the
bribes given them to look away
and obscenity either tolerated or ignored by
the crown you just went up 100 points in my
book lady I look into it you have
my work that's not much of a word
God this kid oh this is so embarrassing
I do regret this friend
oh wow dang oh god
oh yeah yep I was hoping you disappeared does our
father truly dead yes and they're
going to make you king oh damn
where's your brother
let me go he's got the best seat he's up there
there are so many people watching
the queen always
we have not seen Rainier at all why are they gone
deep now is icy nicely done I am rooting
for Allison in this particular situation
and it's a nuanced perspective Mr will be named
Lord commander of the king's God of course he
is my son was hit the crown of his namesake
the Conqueror and Carrie Blackfire his sword
the people remember the ancient
strength of House Targaryen
bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
bad bad bad you look so much like
your mother in certain lights before
Otto killed her plot twist is so awful
Damon get in there sliced it all down more than
once it is proved advantageous to those willing to
feed the Weaver
this is whoa whoa decency
oh no sir
a lot of the men in this
show make me want to throw up
yeah absolutely
with me princess
oh what poor guy the black water's this way
bad feeling about this
such [__]
oh my God is this really happening right now
we have 20 years
mind
I still don't want like common sense right now
with his final breath he whispered to me that you
this is so frustrating and all this it's just like
one child misunderstanding at least let him pass
it off to Eamon and then when he's when's he gonna
be informed of the prophecy and all that stuff
yeah that's a good question who's gonna tell them
wow for as his Spirit left us
he whispered his final wish
that his first born son
aegon should succeed him this man
is so bad his cats went so fast
oh [__] you knew it though yeah
damn you elephant
and privilege wow
Goosebumps everywhere that is
so messed up this is so bad
huh I just feel like Bruno's
being wrong so harshly right now
okay the Crone lift a shining
lamp and light his way to wisdom
oh my God what's race gonna do the crown of
the Conqueror passed down through generations
story gets lost over time
and here we are let the seven bear Witness egg
on Targaryen is the true heir to the iron throne
the tiniest nod lord of the Seven Kingdoms and
protector of the realm egg on the king please clap
God damn you Allison
damn you are
oh yeah now you're starting to like this
oh we are going to have a
full on war in season two
that's what I'm talking about yeah yeah oh yes
fly fly away damn
show her riding him come on show her come on
yes oh my god did you see that look when she was
in the crowd like I'm gonna
mess it up here burn it all
wow what a badass
foreign
dude MVP
all right there is so much to talk
about before we do gotta think
expressvpn because they're loyal and they don't
want to dick us over like how this Situation's
gone down thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
this video guys listen I'm gonna go straight to
the chase here if you're using the internet in
the year of 2022 you ought to be using it with
the protection of a VPN and before I go into the
protection part let me tell you why we first got
a VPN all right it was just for the this purpose
alone you know I was always hearing like YouTubers
people talking about how they were able to access
Netflix in the UK and other things like that via
a VPN and they would have different properties
on there than that of the US and it worked it's
amazing I love the access to it in the world to
do absolutely and right now Express is ranked
number one Business Insider and it works across
all your devices that includes Smart TV which is
perfect for checking out Geo lock content from
all over the world thanks to Express's Global
array of services then yeah like I said that's
literally the first thing we did when we activated
our account they got servers on all across the
world so you can pick and choose literally where
you want to be surfing from for your own safety
or just to check out that content whatever it is
but either way there's always someone out there
looking to swipe or trade your information and
half the time it's your own ISP actively trading
your information to other advertising companies
which is perfectly legal America America yeah so
fortunately you can stop all that and we have had
a we had a really scary situation happen to us a
while ago so we did actually need an expressvpn
for our own protection as well so you can protect
your data 100 we really do vouch for this and yeah
you can enjoy some cool perks while in the process
of using expressvpn as well so to put simply and I
had John write this down for me uh Express it's an
app it reroutes your Internet connection through a
selection of secure servers from all over the
world encrypting your information and keeping
it hidden from anyone who's trying to steal or spy
on it uh thank you for writing that for me I don't
know why you could have just read it yourself
but I appreciate you writing that down I'm just
jealous that you got to read why don't you read
down what I wrote absolutely and if you would
like to reap all those lovely benefits and get an
extra three months for free on a one year package
let me tell you visit our exclusive link which is
expressvpn.com rejects that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s Greg
was adamant that I spell it for you uh.com VPN
spell V with a p and an A as in Victor p is in
pineapples and N is in nacho cheese take too long
to think of what that letter is rejects that's our
code rejects learn more anyway do it look back
to talking about how's the drive wow what a what
a cool episode you don't cut to renero or Damon
once this entire time this whole time you're just
like whoa they're gonna rack like when the fun
yeah don't ruin it for me in this comments you
bastards in Texas so it's just gonna be 20 minutes
of Rainier and screaming what I have successfully
avoided spoilers for this so yeah I think I'm
ruined [__] for me uh yeah that that was a
very tense gripping episode and so conflicting
because you're thrusted into perspectives here
that you know is just not true but then you're
kind of find yourself it's like you could either
just play on the sidelines and observe or you can
start kind of adopting a perspective here and you
know it's like off of course I don't agree with
all with what happened um but I thought one of
the most um enriching emotional tolls that they
managed to ring out of this given situation was
you're like God damn it Allison you don't know
what you're talking about you know you don't
know what happened but then when it came time to
like find aegon and the conversation that she has
with rainey's rainey's sorry that's how I say it
rainey's it's a conversation that she has with
her you know it's like you do find her going but
I wanted to take like some kind of stand against
Otto because he's been a real dick and a lot of
this has been uh his manipulation pulling the
strings so I'm like if this is gonna happen she
should at least have ownership over the situation
you know and I do have it done her way so you
do have that compelling side because at least
in though I have not read the book so at least
in the way it is Illustrated here in this series
I understand where she's coming from all right
do I agree no am I on her side absolutely not
but she does think she's honoring viserys's
dying wish and that's the part where you're
like well if that's the way you think
and feel and believe this right now
um and I understand why you think that given
the circumstances you were being dealt here with
Otto Hightower I I I see why why you feel that all
right all right so then back to the conversation
um all right that was rear camera just cut
randomly okay sorry about that anyway uh
as we're talking I'm Gonna Leave just that I'm
really gonna try and marry the the clips properly
I'm just gonna leave the fact that the camera
got here is that we're all the footage it says
um so yeah when you have this conversation
this debate I find myself like you know I
feel bad for her because she clearly it's it's
such a fascinating seat to be in from I feel
like book readers have no issue I mean like no
screwels you know yeah totally the way I hear
it's every impression I've heard no sympathy
whatsoever don't trust her no matter what they
do on the show don't trust her well I feel like
they're gonna make her worse you can just feel
that happening you know like she is morphing and
morphing over time and then in in some ways with
rainey's of how she sort of empowers um uh
Allison in this moment and even at the very
tail end with the show-off or she could have just
been like you guys are a bunch of sacks of [__]
I'm going to pursue on the flames right now she
didn't there was even a little bit of exchange of
there's a bit of admiration in what you just
did but uh I'm flying off right you played the
game well game recognized games but also I'm
getting the hell out of here yeah follow me if
you want Randy's almost looked at the camera
and was like welcome to the Game of Thrones
flew off you don't got the
stomach for it get out now
uh and then yeah there's so many different
compelling factors here because like Auto
a Hightower is just morphing into
full-on bulging red eyes guys yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah and just watching like I
love the way he plays that character because
it's like it's the more we experience his
strategy and his actions the the greater the
argument becomes for like never ever trusting a
single emotional beat that comes out of him and
I I think he's a fascinating character due to
that he comes back to that thing of just trying
to act in the best interests of the realm and
all that stuff and there are parts of me that
kind of still believe that but yeah like he oh
screw that now yeah a bunch of [__] like he
wasn't plotting that forever yeah yeah and I mean
he seems like the kind of guy who wants to be the
de facto King you know and it was it was almost
a sorry I have to interrupt it was almost as if
when Allison revealed the king's dying wish that
everyone on that Council who was Stephen was like
[__] what did we think to just say that when he
died wow he did the rest of the planning for us
we could have just said he whispered this yeah we
could have done this anytime what is wrong with us
in fact we could have just locked him up killed
him ourselves said he did that and then passed
it off his natural causes what is wrong with us
yeah yeah one it Clues you in like what's so great
about this episode across the board but especially
what's so maddening about this exact situation is
yeah it is like it's so human and in this period
of time especially like it's all word against word
against account against account and so it's
no wonder they do everything so fast because
it's like you expect me to bleed like I love you
pointed that out like even uh aegon sorry seems to
be the one guy who's like really Mom Dad said this
right before he died and no one was there really
um but yeah like like the the mistake made you
know he he misjudges who's with him and that
leads to all this and and then again you know
like all these little fragile again perceptions
and convictions that make up the real tapestry
of what this is so easy to focus on the action
and yet certain of the most pivotal moments
come from just little human errors and I think
that's really beautiful and really imagining and
really fascinating and it makes for like really
tense storytelling because it it contributes
to that idea that anything could happen see
because I just for some reason my mind went
after last week's episode which by the way
I gotta love comments who were like I think you
were confused on what happened at the end there
and then if there were people where I was like
if you just waited 40 seconds literally yeah
like 30 to 40 seconds you would have seen no
I said exactly what you said in that comment
and more I was not confused appreciate appreciate
you looking out though I will say it wasn't mean
spirited I don't want to act like you guys are
being dicks like you guys are actually like wait
it might be confused you know um my own ego was
just getting like what the [__] is I did get it
you know because sometimes you feel like you want
that credit you want the credit for getting stuff
um so but now no one was a dick about it they were
actually if they were actually trying to clarify
in case I forgot in case we didn't understand um
but no I would completely understand what happened
I was under the impression that there was going
to be like like a debate about what to do I didn't
think it was gonna be he said that all right
activate Planet activate operation a God on the
throne we've been plotting this for the past 10
years and all we needed was this one moment yeah
yeah did not think that's how it was gonna go I
thought it was gonna be like a an episode of like
discussion and and some type of because yeah they
had the debate at the beginning with the council
and and I liked the position Allison took screw
it all right I love the way Allison's written in
the show I think she's running great all right
and I'm very very much drawn to her character
like I don't it's an interesting position it's
an honest room to be like I'm so not on your
side but I completely get why you think the way
you're thinking and why you're doing what you're
doing you know like I I I do really love the way
she's written and it's not even like I love to
hate you kind of relationship yeah it's like I I
get you even though I just don't agree with you
um but she was even like that she's so about
because you you do explore that she still has
a moral compass to us to an extent everyone in
the Game of Thrones world has that aspect of to
an extent all right and she has still that
feeling of really she loved viserys and she
wanted to honor she wants to understand which and
she was even like I don't feel like we should go
behind her I'm not I don't want to like she
had that contemplate At first she had that
contemplation we gotta do this now but she did
have that contemplation of I got you know like
viserys wouldn't want she didn't want rhaenyra to
die period plain and simple she didn't want renera
executed even though did he go behind her back
and did this whole thing that's the part that's
so like frustrating it's like it's not even a
conversation happening about this she didn't want
rhaenyra to die and she had reasoning from her own
personal feelings of whatever nostalgic feelings
but also on like knowing viserys wouldn't want
rhaenery to die Mr Family Man Mr like dying moment
it's painful to watch it's an emotion it's it's
weirdly consistent emotional episode as tense and
taught as it is it's weirdly emotional because you
know this is not what viceros wanted like you know
as an audience member what the truth is you know
he did not want this and you it's just knowing
where he left off of like I think I did what I
wanted which was unite my family and everything's
gonna be fine and because of a misunderstanding
yeah because he spoke to the wrong person because
I saw the wrong person in the dark yeah my one
good eyes blind spot yeah because he messed that
up it's now gonna cause a big war the pacifist
he's not right the ultimate irony he's leaving
these gay people call him peaceful peaceful yeah
um it it's painful to watch and then there's all
kinds of people who want us to strip that Throne
you know like Chris Christian's gone all like uh
yeah broke my heart finally yeah that's his
whole performance now yeah yeah I'm loyalty
ulcerer's ready to kill him
yeah I know everything he does you brought my
heart from her like he ran off of me completely
defined his whole existence since then the whole
yeah now his whole goal is just to back the high
tower regime and to see renera suffer as much as
possible yeah yeah well and again like it's it's
all it's it's so beautiful because it's yeah it's
you get steeped in all these personal elements and
angles and I love when they're out in the city
looking for aegon and you have these two pairs
you're watching as Sir Eric and his brother you
know conduct one way and you're watching as two
people who we don't know as personally
are processing the sort of debate that
this represents and then you have two people who
are like totally on the inside of the debate in
aymond and Kristen who are looking for aegon
and the way that that whole convergence comes
and watching as aegon is like dragged back to uh
King's Landing and you know forced to do this and
part part way through you know like the dagger has
I believe the the prophecy on it uh but part of
me was like I don't know I feel like maybe he'll
just kill himself or something like that because
he was really not into this but then you also
watch that turn as he finally sees his court and
all the people and everyone begins to applaud him
and you can see how so it's it's that fascinating
I can't remember exactly what the line was but
but something about you know not being grateful
because of these things that are sort of just like
made available to you when other people have to
work for them and so as as much of a depraved
sort of amoral characters we know aegon to be
I'm fascinated to see where this will take him
because if there's one thing that's made him sort
of fascinating to me it's that he doesn't seem to
care and he actively seems to reject the throne
and so now that he's got it and now that he's got
this taste of you know uh Power and this just this
taste of you know getting the sense for how much
he Lords over uh I I am terrified to see what that
character becomes and then also what that does to
amend because I mean part of me was like yeah this
is that's that other thing of like he's clearly
capable and wants to do it so why not why did
the rules dictate things that could only be aegon
yeah uh yeah and it's all these yeah like there's
so many great elements of here's how our system
works and here's how we need to uphold it but
also here all the little personal aspects that you
know gum up the gears and everything and yeah the
the machinations are wild and and it's fascinating
to me the way that they're able to balance those
two out because you always feel the huge Stakes
but you always feel the very small micro personal
Stakes kind of always percolating between the two
in every given moment while you even have now it
always seemed like there was some type of loyalist
relationship with Otto and Allison you're like oh
it's them going Toe to Toe now now they're skiing
against each other she's tired of being a pawn
and she's going to oh my God the pervert's name
yeah oh God and Lauren it's like Lars was what
Otto was doing you know okay and now Otto's like
out now drunk on his own plan but he was always
like mine just I'm a little Coy about everything I
don't know I mean I mean I could kill I don't want
to kill the White Worm but I could if you wanted
him yeah your dad is really helpful to your dad
and Lars is uh he he's he's just uh he he
really is repulsive he's a very repulsive
character yeah and um these like weird sexual
exchanges that he has with the queen uh or like
like these voyeuristic sexual exchanges like nasty
and he said like I wouldn't want him to meet the
actor if I saw him I'd be like oh my God it's
that guy from a house of the Dragon I'm gonna say
hi I'm like no I don't want to say hi to the guy
let's take a different route let's let's leave the
store I will not be able to see past who he plays
he could be like hi my name is uh wow what are you
doing Ken Walters and I play uh Lars it was a
real hard character to get into and mastering
that accident on the show very difficult but uh
I think I nailed it with my voice acting coach oh
yeah that's a nice pair of sandals you've got on
you seem like you keep your feet real well trimmed
I would not be able to see past the reaction place
oh no yeah this you know that he's got more more
pawns up his sleeve he's just playing now he plays
a slow Slytherin chess game and then you know 100
meters from now they've got like a little finger
there's always there's just it's you're just kind
of watching this generational cycle of like this
one wants thrown this one is little skeeving guy
who serves the hierarchy this one is I don't want
a part of it but I'm going to be a big part of it
you know and everyone's got their own little
archetypes here yeah and who among the people
who can't have the throne but really really want
it will get closest and and Whisper the most
poison into whoever's ear so this was uh this
was a fascinating tale and um I thought reynus
was a freaking awesome after everything she's
been through I thought that was such a cathartic
moment so gratifying yeah I was very very good
I actually just set them a Flames but like out
of every like out of an episode that's like it
keeps you so curled up in tension it is like
such a reward I know but yeah I I'm definitely
uh just for clarification purposes and I mean it
from the bottom of my heart especially when you
could see that this was all wrong it's all wrong
team black all the way I mean I don't
you know I like I like uh actually I
shouldn't mention YouTube is so sensitive
about some some words but there's the CK
CH word that uh Allison drops and talk
about rainey's about like your husband
was that and I was like ah it's nice to
hear they used in an actual definition
yes yeah see where it is yeah gotcha nice
definition word so yeah it's like I know
there's some of course deception and sort
of Lies amongst that but what stance true is
she's the one who's supposed to inherit the
throne bottom line she's the one and uh this
was all deceitful so yeah 100 team black on this
whole situation can I be team renice can I can
I just go there I'm pretty sure she's gonna go
team black yeah this is probably true but that's
what makes a cool character out of her is the fact
that like even though she was been wronged on all
fronts by everyone it's like the end of the day
the honorable thing well yeah and uh I guess the
target of a heavy piece of dishonoring right now
is probably going to be the enemy of my enemy who
will now be my friend yeah yeah it's great writing
great writing overall I'm sure it's a wonderful
books I'm good too after it's the kind of thing
I'm like it's so much more fun I feel like it's
not it wouldn't be if I'm sure it's really fun
and engrossing as it as it shows for people who
have read the book and like the way they talk so
enthusiastically and get so emotional about it the
with the backed up feeling of like you don't even
know what's coming in yeah every time your mind is
blown there's a game of fans Game of Thrones fan
around the corner waiting to go no just you wait
yeah and just you wait so my I like being here
where I'm like I have no clue and I love that yeah
um I can only surmise with the information that's
been given to me and I just love watching the
trajectory of these characters I I think every
performer here is so well so well layered and
um yeah I feel like Otto's the real bad guy of
this whole thing more than all of them I feel like
Auto Hightower is the real villain well yeah I
mean he's this he seems to have the best blend of
he's very smart very cunning he's able to put up
face and you know dude he's able to do the court
stuff and and do the presentable ceremonial
stuff and then he's able to do the really
ugly down and dirty stuff well I mean he's not
yeah he does all this evil [__] and he's not
indulgent usually like he got so intense
and you felt that ticking clock by him
that that race against the clock that was
all he feel that just with auto Hightower
um like he's on the street like that this guy is
this guy is right now he's like we're on crunch
time right now yeah we only have a few short
hours to solidify our our master plan once we
announce it he's dead we gotta we gotta announce
a nuke in the new error all right guys thanks for
being here this was an awesome awesome awesome
awesome episode um you guys rock uh thank you
to expressvpn uh subscribe click that Bell
leave a like last but not least let's do it
Lord Everett of house Baker you my friend seem
like the kind of person who probably would die
in this world you're too nice man you're too
friendly and kind to us and uh you know you might
make it by if you were to live by your namesake
like if you were a baker somewhere in the city
not too close to flea bottom you know where like
the kid fights happen you might make it through
but honestly I'm glad you live in this day and
age with us I don't want to see you maimed and
mangled by the harshness of the era in the realm
and all that stuff I'm not even gonna mention
your middle name this time it's just Everett of
house Baker because that's who you are for reals
that's the real essence of you and we are glad
that you share it with us here we're glad that
you are loyal to team orange and red if that's
our colors I guess and and you know our house
Sigil of of the Celluloid we appreciate you uh
swearing fealty to us and bending the knee and
we love you and we'll catch you uh on
the next one be well always a pleasure